[Musique]
oh
ils ont fait la une de l'actualité
les métiers à vaison starifié voir ce
cas tu fier pour ne parler que d'eux on
ne voyait qu'eux et puis jour au
lendemain ils ont quitté l'éphémère
panthéon de la gloire moderne les projos
de l'info ont éclairé ailleurs et le
public les apps est aussi vite qu'ils
avaient quittée l'incognito ils sont
retournés à l'anonymat qui était-il d'où
venaient-ils pourquoi et comment
avait-il acquis leur célébrité de quelle
façon eux et leurs proches avait t-il
vécu lors de getaria pour quelle raison
ont-ils disparu que s'est il passé
depuis bref que sont ils devenus dans
tout le monde en a parlé à travers
d'abord des archives de la gloire puis
une enquête sur leur vie aujourd'hui et
enfin une interview vérité je vais vous
raconter leur histoire
voici tout le monde en a parlé
l'émission qui rallume la lumière
[Musique]
j'accueille hermine dé clermont tonnerre
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
hermine de clermont-tonnerre à sèvres à
bord de son bolide une authentique mini
journée qui commence qu'il continu ait
déjà commencé avec mes enfants allez y
tiennent
première étape de la journée une radio
pour laquelle elle tient une chronique
hebdomadaire sur l'art de vivre
cette partie portait déjà
c'est pas l'usagé anglais d'autres sont
là que l'on s'adresse à la personne qui
nous est présenté à une dame on dire à
madame est un homme grâce à peine finie
et avant son deuxième rendez vous elle
s'accorde une pause plaisir vous emmène
chez un fabricant chante
que j'aime bien chez nous habiller les
voitures j'adore les courses femmes
comme mon père tout comme pas penser aux
passionnés des sports mécaniques elle
participe en effet à des courses
automobiles comme le rallye des
princesses qu'elle fait chaque année
et gares hôtels à
être mignonne
ah
les bijoux
howie
pas quelle merveille c'est sympa c'est
là aussi
voilà c'est fait
magna
ah
j'adore j'adore
ce
que j'attends d'habiller je repasse
quand tu veux je repassais powell ont
fait vrombir quelques petits moteurs par
plaisir et par passion et par
merci pour ces c minutes de bonheur
[Applaudissements]
aller retour au travail toujours suivi
de sa fidèle chienne qu'elle passe son
temps à cherche
baker hughes
cette fois elle a rendez vous avec son
éditeur alors ça fait un petit moment
mais oui absolument pas sur une nouvelle
aventure en est reparti sur une nouvelle
aventure on continue on continue la
politesse la politesse c'est le livre
dont elle sort à nouveau tome et devinez
le thème l'art de vivre eh oui son sujet
de prédilection market oui moi j'adore
ce qui devient une sorte de label elle
est à la fois un pied dedans le passé
dans les traditions et au lendemain
parce que elle délivre à savoir vie
moderne et humainement un extraordinaire
je serai là beaucoup de coeur de dire ça
on peut résumer comme ça
si j'aime bien j'adore
lui il est temps de rentrer à la maison
pour une soirée entre amis autour de la
cuisine diététique bien sûr bonsoir
walkom pour les hommes pour la suite de
la journée
mas est réelle elle est grave
notre chef
aujourd'hui tu va nous concocter des
petits plats extrêmement équilibrée
diététique
plein de vitamines de minéraux sait
exactement comment ma vie tous les jours
c'est qu'on peut faire attention aux
animaux
si bien équilibrée si on lui donne tout
ce qu'il faut il a besoin absolument
du tout regardez la vie pour garder la
forme et tout ce qu'il peut y avoir donc
on espère que ça va plaire aux invités
ce soir mais je pense qu'ils devraient
être séduits normalement
sa tête
aux deux et on entend peser
c'est pas obligatoirement simplement
pour un programme minceur qu'elle la
prime aussi programme gourmand voilà
pour moi ça va ensemble la minceur et
gourmandises ça va ensemble la
gourmandise est un plaisir qui se
partagent termine se retrouver soit
entre amis avec un merveilleux chef qui
nous fait un dîner où
il va pouvoir manger ou mal j'ai mal
j'ai
un nom c'est ce qui me fait plaisir
c'est un bon jour je
t'aime je t'aime mon coeur une façon de
vivre qu'elle a su transmettre
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
hermine de clermont-tonnerre hermine
bienvenue sur plateau tout mandat par
les genres thiery vous êtes né à
boulogne billancourt le 3 février 1966
troisième enfant sur quatre vous
appartenez à l'une des huit familles
ducale française et vous porter le titre
de princesse titre attribuées au 16ème
siècle par le saint-empire romain
germanique
alors mais clermont tonnerre ont le
droit d'entrer à cheval dont la
basilique saint pierre
j'adorerais le faire et je choisirais
plutôt à cheval blanc et
en amazone ou rouge bordeaux là mais on
en rêve alors vous avez les armes
déclamant tonnerre deux clés de
saint-pierre tatoué sur la fesse droite
je vais vous êtes bien renseigné
on ne peut rien vous cacher ses tissus
en cas d'accident ce a su marquer ou que
je suis au fer rouge votre père le duc
de clermont-tonnerre était colonel au
1er rep le régiment étranger de
parachutistes et il s'est illustré lors
du putsch d'alger avec le général salan
contre le général de gaulle vous dites
ça a gâché les dernières années de sa
vie il est mort d'un cancer à 60 ans
risquent en fait qu'il a été nommé
général et c'était l'année du
bicentenaire de la révolution
et mitterrand et du duc de
clermont-tonnerre prince à clermont
tonnerre l'habit de l'année du
bicentenaire nommé général non ayant
fait le putsch nom et vous avez
l'impression d'être insultée d'être
dégradée parce que c'est vraiment le
terme vous êtes dégradé et ça a été très
dur ça l'a énormément blessée absolument
alors que lui à l'époque du putsch il ne
faisait que qu'un quart mais les
convictions qui étaient les siennes
commercial que tous les gens officié en
tant que militaire et quand on défend
quelque chose on le défend jusqu'au bout
et on part pas en courant des calmants
dans le problème
alors vos souvenirs d'enfance ne sont
pas ceux du château familial du berry
mais plutôt ceux des bases militaires
perdu dans les champs de betteraves
vue grammatical sordide je sais pas ce
que j'ai fait une fois seule fois et
nous c'est sûr au contraire c'est qu'on
a passé beaucoup de temps dans des
endroits merveilleux de jolies maisons
de jolis propriété et vous vous
retrouvez dans un camp militaire à
sissonne parce que personne ne sait où
se trouvent six heures c'est à côté de
l'en c'est une énorme base militaire us
que mon père comment des 80 mille hommes
et
j'aurais dû plus adoré en profiter mais
non beaucoup trop cher alors vous êtes
la chouchoute de ce père colonel mais
vous avez des rapports tendus avec votre
mère qui vous corrige la cravache oui
mais le cavaliere alors elle corrigeait
ses enfants la cravache chez moi un peu
plus que les autres parce que c'était un
petit peu plus dissipés il faut dire que
vous avez une enfance turbulente et une
adolescence mouvementée
normal un film et la bip et des cigares
oui
mais pourquoi ça devrait être réservée
qu'aux hommes c'est un
archétype de du côté masculin et macho
de la vie pourquoi on devrait avoir des
petites motos des mobylettes et les
garçons des énormes quand votre
confiance une peugeot 103 vous préférez
une harley davidson quoi oui absolument
et j'ai toujours là ils vous envoient en
pension chez les soeurs de sainte croix
de jérusalem alors là ils font durer le
froid des dortoirs c'est une vie
extrêmement difficiles on vous apprend à
baisser les yeux lorsque vous croisez un
un jeune homme absolument est ce qu'il
ya un grand parc et bien et dans les
temps des garçons qui se baladait
réserve a bien croisé des pensionnaires
et les bonnes soeurs quand on faisait
des tours de rond 10e et moiselle le
péché parce baisser les halls péché
parce
qu'elle vous amène quand même à rome les
bonnes soeurs pour baiser la main du
pape qu'on aime c'est classe oui j'ai vu
ma mère supérieure il n'y a pas très
longtemps et elle m'a dit vous souvenez
hermine lors du jubilé on était très mal
placé vous inquiétez pas mais ramaré je
m'en charge emmené toute la pension
derrière vous et je veux non je m'en
souviens pas des choses qui est déjà un
tempérament
après l'épreuve du bac vous détourner un
autocar qui vous ramène à la pension
comme les bonnes formes ont mis chef de
chef de classe chefs de toutes les
terminales et au moment du bac explique
à meyrannes maric quand on prend le bus
à 9 heures près de compiègne dans notre
pension qu'on va arriver à compiègne
qu'on descend du bus donc voilà on
remonte on a les sujets un petit peu
tard jeudi marie on va rester une demi
heure entre qui nous que le but sera
maître de compiègne à cuisent lamothe
est resté une demi heure on va stresser
on va voir les profs on va pas déjeuner
est-ce qu'on peut rester déjeuner votre
sandwich à compiègne et meyrals mari me
dit non hermine vous ne changerez pas
les règles de la pension c'est comme ça
depuis toujours donc je monte dans le
bus le matin jeudi si vous voulez celles
qui veulent rentrer rentrer et le
deuxième je fais la même chose et
personne ne veut rentrer à l'heure du
dev donc les bonnes soeurs m'ont
attribué deux détournements d'autobus
c'est un peu facile quand même à ce plan
amoureuse est assez précoce vous avez le
premier amant à 15 ans il en a le double
avec un jour mais en fait il voulait se
marier vouliez pas normal a annoncé
beaucoup trop jeune le deuxième vous
dites c'est un grand avocat drôle et
pétillant donc on cherche les américains
américain non c'est pas la peine qu'on
essaie
lui la 58 ans n'est pas que jamais le 18
j'ai toujours une tendance pour déjà un
peu mur intéressant pétillant je ne suis
son pétillant mais mais il ya peut-être
aussi le côté qui rassure le côté
paternel de la personnes plus âgées
volant le fait aussi d'avoir perdu mon
père un peu jeune et je lançais pas
besoin de ces canalise non c'est très
facile en temps j'ai eu une enfance
heureuse et pétillante et sympathique
mais c'est vrai je regrette de ne pas
avoir connu mon enfin ne pas avoir gardé
mon père parce que c'est que je
connaissais divinement bien je savais
parfaitement le mener par le bout du nez
mais j'aurais pu les garder plus
longtemps
en juin 1984 finissait par avoir votre
bac et vous annoncer à vos parents vous
voulez travailler dans la mode et ils
vous disent tu sais qu'il n'ya que des
drogués des dans le métier j'ai
dit à ma mère je vais faire une école de
stylisme et enfin vous êtes complètement
folle ma peau faire il n'y a que des et
puis tu étais nordine et vous votre main
oui mais mes parents tout le monde se
dit vous c'est une habitude tradition
c'est le joli soucis en merde c'est plus
sympa d'études dans l'intimité
alors avant de deux ans après l'école de
signes nous rentrer chez dior d'être
c'est quand même temps chez dior deux
ans et demi faisait quoi j'ai commencé
par baby dior et dur lingerie et ensuite
dominic moore les petits durs monsieur
ensuite il ya la parenthèse indienne
alors là vous commencez par rencontre un
dénommé yogesh gupta qui vient à paris
monter le restaurant vishnou et là vous
partez là-bas quoi vous devenez folle
dingue alors your gun du t1 financier il
avait 16 restaurants dans paris dans les
pattes et je suis parti en un pour
décorer ses restaurants donc je suis
parti avec son épouse geneviève de
l'entv et voilà j'ai passé trois mois en
inde a cherché des tissus des matériaux
des chaises des
voix là bas vous donne est passionné par
l'hindouisme
je suis attiré par cette chaleur
générosité gentillesse beauté beauté et
donc j'ai ce côté où on vous prend comme
vous êtes tous avec votre originalité ou
vous des fauves au travers voilà en fait
quand même persuadé à un moment d'avoir
été dans une vie antérieure montage
image la princesse pour qui le maharadja
fait construire le taj mahal quand
j'aurai bien aimé mais moi je suis
persuadé dans une vie antérieure oui je
l'avais non une âme indienne peut-être
me re année j'aimerais bien qu'on m'ait
pas mais l'important c'est de faire du
bien oui c'est pas d'avoir
des bijoux autour de la tête ensuite
vous lancer dans les relations publiques
et les médias
parallèlement vous collaborez à point de
vue on vous voit dans l'émission star et
couronne vous commencez la publication
de vos livres des livres consacrés au
savoir-vivre et au savoir et mais avec
beaucoup de succès l'abonné star de lui
très connu c'était plein de choses que
j'aime plein de choses quelle a été la
réaction de la famille clermont-tonnerre
quand vous avez commencé à faire de la
télé des livres de la presse à l'aller
livre ma mère m'a dit alors franchement
s'il y en avait eu l'avancé gay critique
de chaussures savoir yves c'est
franchement pas vous mâcher rémy et
j'avoue mais pourquoi pourquoi j'ai
écrit ce livre si d'abord parce qu'on me
l'a demandé surexcités drôle de faire ça
d'un côté un peu pétillon amusant et pas
vieille france avec des règles un peu
bon ancien mais il faut réactualiser la
vie tous les jours c'est plus et plus
haut j'ai mis des chaussures en ans les
heures avec mon sac en crocodile non ce
pas la vie ne s'arrête pas là le savoir
ils s'arrêtent pas là et donc j'ai
trouvé ça très amusant et ça m'amusait
parce que c'est vraiment long
m'attendais pas et j'aime bien être là
où on m'attend pas aux relations que les
médias ont toujours été bonnes non oui
toujours toujours toujours à coeur des
gens voir mais sinon j'y vais pas rires
je
voilà quand j'aide à promo pour un livre
pour une émission pour pour quelque
chose il veut mais sinon non j'ai pas de
raison ma vie passée importante
intéressante pour en parler pendant des
heures un petit petit peu j'avais de
l'argent et tout ça est remis je suis
bien artiste c'est à dire que des
finances est pas mon fort je peux une
grande championne pour gagner de
l'argent quand j'ai des énormes groupes
qui venait de racheter orange pour sept
milliards c'est une lumière à en
angleterre au jeu puis une somme
astronomique et c'était mes clients ne
pourriez pas à baisser un peu le contrat
j'ai un bon si ça vous fait plaisir
raconte ça mon frère aîné qui me dit
mais ma pauvre chérie tu feras jamais de
business il pèse mais des milliards
voilà alors son plan amoureux ça a dû
vous vous rapporter un certain nombre de
davanture tout ça non tu pas suis pas
une dévoreuse d'hommes j'aime les
histoires d'amour j'aime j'aime les
passions et voilà et même si temps en
temps ça a pu déranger ou étonné une
passionnée l'histoire incroyable avec un
master qu'une forme c'est un gros coup
ça a été ma grande histoire d'amour ça a
été le père de mes enfants et ça a été
quelqu'un de s'aimer passionnément
je serai tué pourquoi au je pense
incompatibilité un moment donné la vie
changer son change peut-être des deux
côtés et on n'a plus grand chose à c'est
le meilleur moment toute cette époque
c'était quoi maj ou des histoires avec
alister tout ce que j'ai saisie et mais
je me suis amusé au gros stage me suis
amusé avec mon émission de tf1 ce samedi
j'aime la vie
donc je ne sais pas faire quelque chose
que je n'aime pas
ouais et le pire moment le pire moment
mais c'est évidemment la séparation
s'est jamais joly s'est jamais
sympathique de d'être déçu d'être prises
d'être whip it malheureuse parce que
c'est j'étais persuadé de finir mes
jours avec à leicester et on avait tout
pour finir nos jours ensemble et puis
puis ça c'est pas sympa marché à un
moment donné
il ya des choses qui peuvent se creuser
comme ça et ça passe et ça peut repartir
l'accès à sa fin que la chaque groupe
aux plages et moi qui aime bien la
conduite et voilà et les belles voitures
et les gros moteurs
mais j'ai vite et que ça devienne trop
dangereux et de me prendre les murs
alors on vous retrouve en 2010 dans la
ferme célébrités en afrique
c'était difficilement
l'ambiance est extrêmement difficile
parce qu'on essaie de mettre de la
méchanceté de la haine de la discorde de
l'antipathie et de la bêtise et moi qui
aime que les choses jolies sympathique
et pétillante tout ce que je détestais
les quatre premières semaines ça allait
à peu près parce qu'il restait des gens
intelligents il y avait eu une
conversation avec des neurones et pains
cuits poisson rouge et je m'excuse
auprès des poissons rouges parce qu'il
était en dessous des poissons rouges et
c'est super dur là la méchanceté cette
bouche mais je félicite pas de tf1 pour
sa solution était un flop en disaient
ouais mais savent ça fait plutôt plaisir
de savoir que la médiocrité ne marche
pas alors aujourd'hui vous êtes
nostalgique de l'époque de stars et
cours de tout s'annonçait nom dit tout
chaque chose a son temps et il est
plutôt normal de s'amuser d'aller en
boîte de nuit à 18 1 22 d'avoir de
belles histoires d'amour à 28 d'avoir de
grandes histoires d'amour où 30 des
patients à 35 des enfants et ont grandi
la vie c'est grandir
si c'était à refaire votre vie armin
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil cette séparation je gérais avant
mieux quelques années avant j'aurais été
moins indulgente moins gentil moins
j'aurais été plus rigoureuse j'aurais
mieux protéger la prêt le jour vous
allez mourir que celui qu'on marque sur
leur tombe six hommes naissent égaux
note même si tous moi non un devises et
clermont tonnerre bravo bravo c'est très
agréable mais la lumière sur voir merci
mille fois
[Musique]
j'accueille le docteur guy blair
sortie sans commentaire du docteur du
blair après son audition dans les locaux
de la police judiciaire l'ex médecin de
françois mitterrand a été entendu
pendant près de quatre heures comme
témoin dans le cadre de l' enquête
préliminaire pour atteinte au secret
professionnel sur plainte de la famille
mitterrand après l' ordonnance de référé
prise hier qui interdit la diffusion du
libre les éditions plon n'ont pas encore
décidé si elle faisait appel elles ont
quinze jours pour le faire en france 40
mille exemplaires du grand secret ont
été vendus mercredi unique journée de
diffusion la fnac a décidé de reverser
les bénéfices de cette vente à la
recherche sur le cancer
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
claude gugler dans les bouches du rhône
en pleine nature
c'est entouré d'olivier qu'il profite de
son havre de paix et s'adonne à sa
passion la photographie d'oiseaux
la photographie les oiseaux c'est des
heures et des heures d'attentes pour une
photo il y à un pic épeiche qui est dans
le chêne on va tâcher de le prendre et
puis y est de vous le montrer
[Musique]
les oiseaux il suffit d'attendre y en a
et ne pas leur faire peur c'est
l'art de la photographie
et la patience ne suffit pas toujours
parfois il faut changer de poste
d'observation
je prends en apercevoir
on regardera il n'est pas peu fier de
l'avoir enfin rattraper cet oiseau à
travers son objectif
un pic épeiche c'est un pic épeiche sur
le chaîne qui est là que nous venons de
voir je vais
l'imprimé on va regarder voilà mon pic
épeiche
une passion qu'il anime depuis des
années voici quelques cinquante mille
photos prises à travers le monde tous
les albums
l'équateur le costa rica la tanzanie les
galapagos le chili çà cette eau aux
galapagos
[Musique]
il est l'heure pour claude de remplir
ses obligations de la journée direction
la mairie de cuges les pins une petite
ville de 5000 habitants dont il est le
premier adjoint au maire depuis 2007
[Musique]
plainte et quelques années que j'ai pu
faire ce mais fonctionne et du je suis
maintenant premier adjoint responsable
des finances et du personnel et de
l'informatique
bonjour c'est dur mais bonjour qui
voulaient bien rentré dans mon bureau
prenant son rôle très à coeur il va
jusqu'à recevoir ces rendez-vous dans le
bureau du maire
[Musique]
la journée continue au secours populaire
de la ville visite hebdomadaire madame
la présidente
madame lamoureux secrétaire général ham
la seconde où tu vas bien ma chérie
convient tout à fait en forme la madame
mauricette lamoureux qui est la
présidente du secours populaire qui
dirige l'établissement depuis combien de
temps maintenant ça fait 7 car cinq ans
son secours populaire à cuges il y
aurait des gens qui resteraient sur le
sur le
le carreau toutes les semaines une
distribution de vivres est organisé et
claude vérifie que tout est prêt à
partir de 16h30 à peu près temps
d'entendre les familles vient dont
celles qui sont inscrites sur la liste
de maurice est amoureux bientôt et on va
leur distribuer certains noms aux deux
produits est venu
comme ça bon ma petite morrish est un
grand merci un assez bon c'est pour tous
au revoir au revoir ma belle
de retour chez lui il est accueilli par
le gardien de la maison son chat
ça c'est mon chat bonjour calypso
dernière tâche de la journée claude va
chercher de quoi dîner dans son potager
un poivron ni donc amoureux de la nature
et de la bonne cuisine 6 les petits
bourgs rond vert alors qu'ils sont
délicieux free voilà on les trempe comme
comme une frite dans la friteuse et
c'est un régal alors j'aime bien être là
la vue que j'ai sûr que j'ai été assez
extraordinaire à l'aller
ce grand-père de dix-huit petits-enfants
coule désormais des jours heureux en
provence
m
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
le docteur gugler claude bienvenue sur
le plateau de tout le monde a parlé vous
êtes né le 14 mai 1934 à paris dans le
14e votre père était suisse allemand
géologue il avait établi la cartographie
du laos du siam est du tonga l'indochine
de l'époque puis vers un petit peu de
renseignements pour le deuxième bureau
sinon il a dû en faire le gouvernement
français quand il est devenu français
lui a demandé compte tenu du fait qu'il
parlait huit langues les suisses sont
des gens qui parlent beaucoup même s'ils
sont quelquefois très muet
alors qu'au retour d'une mission
la gangrène l'emportent en 48 heures
tout à fait c'est un
quelque chose
et qui est dans ma tête parce qu'on me
l'a dit je ne les ai pas vécu j'avais 6
ans de mon père j'ai très peu de
souvenirs puisqu'il était tout le temps
soit en mission sans un travail de
terrain de recherche de cartographie
comme le font tous les géologues et
il est mort
on s'est toujours interrogé nous ses
enfants aiment ses amis sur les raisons
de sa mort
ma mère était une scientifique un très
intellectuel très brillante h&m évolué
que je me penche trop sur le pourquoi
ces reste un point d'interrogation car
votre mère géologue elle aussi tout à
fait on lui doit la découverte des
gisements pétroliers du sahara et des
landes ce qui est quand même pas rien
tout à fait tout à fait sacrée famille
oui alors vous passez votre prime
enfance à rabat au maroc
alors vous regardez de vagues souvenirs
de cornes de gazelle avec le thé le
chaouch de mon père qui était le celui
de s'occuper donc des affaires de mon
père et de ma mère et qui nous invitait
dans la médina à prendre le thé avec les
fameuses cornes de gazelle et cornes de
gazelle c'était pour moi délit suprême
les scorpions mais ça c'était un ver
colomb béchar où on allait passer
quelques vacances et ou de nous était
interdit de quand on était petit de
faire quoi que ce soit avec mon frère
qui a deux zones différence avec moi
nous allions chercher des scorpions que
l'on prenait pour s'amuser et la rouge
ce que nous avons reçu voilà c'est
ponctuel mais mes souvenirs de du maroc
tout à fait alors à la mort de votre
père en 1940 vous rentrer en métropole à
toulouse je voudrais un petit détail
humoristique si je puis dire de cette
rentrée en france c'est que les trains
marocain qui devait nous amener prendre
le bateau à oran pour traverser la
méditerranée comme nous sommes arrivés
avec eux des heures de retard le bateau
était parti et on a dû prendre le
suivant et je rappellerai que le bateau
qu'on aurait dû prendre cette laie
lamoricière il a coulé corps et biens
dans la baie de marseille on aurait dû
être voyez le hasard fait des shows
voilà quand vous arrivez à toulouse
c'est moins drôle parce que c'est la
guerre dont les tickets de rationnement
les galoches en bois tout à fait c'est
une période très dure très triste
d'abord notre mère puisqu'on nous sommes
quatre enfants notre mère devait
travailler pour nourrir si je puis dire
travailler aux pétroles d'aquitaine
comme on était au début portionné à
sainte barbe ou les punitions
corporelles existait c'était pâques
encore chez les franciscains on n'avait
pas à manger on était obligé de voler
ont été obligés de pour moi qui n'étais
est-elle troisième c'était les habits
suivant c'était les chaussures un petit
peu éculé les galoches comme je le
rappelais effectivement c'était pas une
vie même si toulouse est une ville rose
alors en plus la maison est en phase d
usines dewoitine donc ils sont bombardés
la nuit d'où nous avions dans le jardin
un abri un creuset dans lequel nous
descendions la nuit ont quelquefois
notre mère nous emmener parce qu'elle
est trop de risques j'ai une amie à elle
qui habitait à côté de la gare matabiau
qui était
et on descendait l'avenir les abris
alors la fin de la guerre débarqué à
paris à janson de sailly vous êtes
condisciple de jean becker le
réalisateur de jacques lafleur le le
héros de la nouvelle calédonie de
philippe labro écrivain journaliste
effectivement il y avait pour nous
jeunes et un peu pauvre je dois dire de
voir
jacques lafleur de voir
jean becker avec des costumes
magnifiques et sapé comme demi
on allait faire des parties d'échecs au
bois de boulogne ont séché les cours on
avait chacun une préférence et
finalement ont formé une bande d'amis
assez sympathique alors vous qui vouliez
devenir juge ou avocat vous allez
devenir maître ça effectivement j'aurais
voulu être avocat ou mais peut être
étais je trop paresseux pour faire des
études supérieures
alors vous voulez vous spécialiser dans
plusieurs disciplines la cardiologie
l'hématologie la cancérologie ce qui
fait qu évidemment vous installer très
tard et là vous garder un pied à
l'hôpital et un pied dans votre cabinet
dans le 6e arrondissement à paris xème
arrondissement est un quartier tout à
fait particulier participent à ce que
vous devenez le médecin des artistes
picasso
salvador dali rené char oui oui c'est
tout à fait vrai vous soyez aussi les
hommes politiques et le premier contact
avec la famille errance et en 1967 quand
vous venez soigner la mère de danielle
mitterrand madame vous au domicile des
mitterrand rue guynemer j'avais comme on
dit vulgairement pignon sur rue
puisqu'il était à côté de chez eux un de
leurs amis à la mort de
jean dayan qui était le médecin de la
famille use et mitterrand leur a dit
mary blair qui hélas idées et il est
bien tu verras il est bien bon et je
suis monté là pour entrer dans la
famille voilà alors pendant plus de dix
ans vous allez poursuivre aux activités
dans votre cabinet de la rue saint
placide à la clinique des soeurs
augustines et vous occuperez de françois
mitterrand entre autres à l'époque il
est insolent de bonne santé est
résolument hostile aux médicaments 1 je
dirais même que et quand ils venaient en
consultation que ce soit la clinique où
dans mon cabinet ou quand j'allais chez
lui c'était toujours pour me dire de ce
médicament un bon qu'est-ce que j'ai mon
syriens ainsi rien non c'est non mais je
n'avais rien alors lorsque françois
mitterrand est élu en 1981 vous devenez
son conseiller médical spécial il a 64
ans c'est un roc il a aucun problème de
santé est d'ailleurs le premier bulletin
de santé dit rien à signaler tout va
bien effectivement enfin une batterie
d'examens comme il l'avait demandé comme
il avait souhaité que cela fût et ses
batteries d'examens cliniques et
biologiques de montres strictement rien
donc ras mais à l'automne 1981 en voyage
au mexique
mitterrand a de fortes douleurs
lombaires au retour aux faits des
examens assez clandestinement d'ailleurs
val de grâce et le verdict tombe cancer
de la prostate avec métastases trois ans
à vivre alors pourquoi n'avait-on pas vu
ça lors des examens du premier bulletin
de santé parce que on ne fait des
examens que sur une symptomatologie
maintenant les faits même sens
symptomatologie ou se dire que vous
n'avez scanner n'avait rien il ya
l'époque ne se taisent faisait pas comme
ça d'une part et d'autre part on ne ne
dit pas quelqu'un qui paraît être en
bonne santé et bien je vais vous faire
un scanner cérébral pour découvrir un
anévrisme ou marié rennes pour découvrir
un anévrisme je dire on ne veut pas
faire un corps entier ou faire une
scintigraphie osseuse pour s'émanciper
alors qu'il ne souffre de rien ce sont
des examens coûteux se sont dit on et
même s'ils ont maintenant c est moins
mais nous sommes quand même nous
médecins responsables de quelqu'un ce
qu'ils appellent la sécurité sociale est
demandée plein d'examen pour rien ouais
me semble être inutile or ce monsieur
était devenu président de la république
mais que je suis qui n'avait aucun signe
clinique d'apple on dit
car il est vraisemblable que
c'est cette symptomatologie
découverte en novembre 1980 un existe
est peut-être en avant mais était
complètement occulté val je puis dire
n'était révélatrice de rien rien rien
aucun signe et je veux je pense qu'aucun
médecin n'aurait pu trouver alors là on
lui dit vous avez trois ans à vivre
quand on vient d'être élu président la
république c'est horrible parce qu'ils
l'avaient attendu pendant pendant toutes
ces années d'être président
au moment où il est président c'est vrai
ce coup le condamne c'est vrai horrible
alors aussitôt mitterrand vers où ils
info il vous dit on n'en parle pas même
à daniel et lorsque vous allez lui faire
sa perfusion à 7h30 du matin rue de
bièvre si des fois elle vous demande
pourquoi vous êtes là vous dites c'est
un rhumatisme récalcitrants oui à partir
du moment où le patient lui-même demande
à ce que les choses ne soient pas dit
à qui que ce soit vous devez vous plier
à ces exigences patiente donc de trouver
une excuse
si
je ne souhaite pas qu'on dise à ma femme
ou à maison pour le moment que je suis
malade le médecin alors évidemment c'est
un petit peu plus délicat lorsque on est
dans une situation aussi attentes à 1 10
on a une image et auquel il faut pas
toucher donc ça posait un peu plus de
problèmes que pour un patient ordinaire
alors lorsqu'arrivent les chances du
deuxième bulletin de santé là il est
plus question de transparence vous vous
suggérez d'au moins parler d'examen mais
mitterrand est catégorique il vous dit
on ne peut rien révélé c'est un secret
d'état et pour bien vous faire
comprendre dans quelle situation vous
êtes il vous dit vous êtes liés par ce
secret tout à fait vous avez là une
documentation tout à fait au fait des
choses ils lui dirent cher monsieur oui
oui c'est tout à fait vrai nom le jeu
mettra d'une tout petit détail
supplémentaire c'est qu'en fait compte
tenu des résultats que j'avais je lui
dis très simplement sur on ne fait rien
on laisse passer l'échéance 1 on ne fait
plus de bulletins de santé oui je ne
veux pas mais si j'ai promis aux
français de dire jeudi mais alors je dis
que non vous ne le dites pas ça a été
une petite partie d'arrêt tombe entre
nous deux jusqu'à ce qu'ils arrivent à
me convaincre bon certains à cette
époque m'ont dit mais vous n'êtes pas
parti dont on n'abandonne pas un malade
on n'abandonne pas un malade quand on
est médecin ou qu'on aime son métier
khalti de juin qui soit un chauffeur de
taxi ou qu'il soit président de la
république nation donc le troisième
communiqué c'est tout va bien rien à
signaler et alors pour faire face aux
rumeurs mitterrand donne une interview
dans laquelle il dit que tout va bien
vous avez une chose c'est que
et l'avait l'histoire l'a montré c'est
que ce monsieur
a merveilleusement
réagi à la thérapeutique et que je
pourrais
je les dis défier quiconque à travers
les résultats des examens de 1982 de
dire qu'il avait quelque chose ouais que
ce soit des examens cliniques qui a été
donnée par le professeur steg examens
cliniques sur la normalité ou au
contraire l'anomalie non professeur seck
disait lui-même au président de la
république et vous êtes comme un homme
de votre âge en occultant le choc qui ne
n'était plus visible même par les
examens biologiques avoir effectivement
miraculeusement l'énergie de françois
mitterrand revient et pendant quelques
années le cancer se tait complètement
vous vous le suivez donc quand même et
vous accepté d'endosser un rôle de
composition pour protéger le secret du
président vous cacher un peu derrière le
masque du bénéf serviable non alors vous
à passer à l'elysée avec vos favoris
comme ça tout le monde voulait gentille
évidemment personne c'est la vie ça me
fait plaisir de pouvoir rire
c'est tout à fait ça ça a été un jeu de
composition pour moi d'être d'être beau
vous savez ce d'être le plus proche
possible de ce qu'ils regardent
qu'est-ce que quand on est très proche
de quelqu'un et bien
on le voit plus avec combien de gens
dans la confidence je dirais que
allez peut-être pas une dizaine à main -
un peu - amis ou politique mais danielle
mitterrand le savait non pas du tout pas
du tout sûr que 1992 mais alors on mai
1988 françois mitterrand est réélu il a
oublié sa maladie tout va bien et elle
se réveille en 1992 et c'est là que ses
liens avec vous vont se distendre parce
que désormais mitterrand a pris
conscience de la mort on l'a aidé devant
son problème il ne peut plus regarder en
face celui qui sait tout je dirais qu'en
1992 est opérée dans une première
intervention en 1992 après son discours
avec philippe seguin sur maastricht à la
sorbonne et on l'opère le lendemain
matin tout ce passe bien dans ce que
vous dites docteur c'est que quand il a
fait cette émission de télévision avec
ce gain et guillaume durand le lendemain
matin il sait qui va subir l'opération
je crois que l'émission c'est a duré une
partie de l'après midi on on s'est
séparés pour aller dîner chacun de notre
côté on s'est donné rendez-vous sa
voiture est venu me prendre
rue dufour je crois ou quelque chose
comme ça nous nous sommes montrés à
cochin où il a été opéré le lendemain
matin par le professeur steg d'alors
l'année 92 est encore une année
je ne dirais pas correct mais
françois mitterrand était un homme
de la terre et qui a toujours refusé
dans sa tête que l'on s'attaque à sa
chair il le disait lui-même et b vous
rendez pas que vous êtes en train à deux
de m'ouvrir et de c'est vous qui allez
disséminées tout ça c'est pas moi moi je
je je maintiens tout ça malheureusement
la symptomatologie était telle qu'il
fallait l'opérer mais c'est plutôt 93 93
et 94 qui vont être des années un peu
charnière voyez c est la deuxième
intervention ses 94 la deuxième
intervention beaucoup plus difficile et
c'est à partir de ce moment là que au
live il est en face de la mort mais il a
souvent été dans nos relations
intellectuels se et vous le savez vous
même combien de fois il parlait de la
mort c'est écrit dans tous les les
livres de biographique sur lui ses
visites dans les cimetières ise cc c'est
parler de la mort en général mais il
m'en parlait même à moi et je lui avais
cette réflexion je lui disais mais
attendez tu disais pas fichés moi la
paix mais ça va être du mari avait
quelquefois dû dire si je me rappelle
avec votre idée vous êtes encore vous
avez encore envie de séduire vin est un
séducteur qui avait encore envie de
séduire je dis pas séduire les femmes
séduire au sens vrai du terme les
humains les hommes par votre a eu par
votre regard vous voulez les séduire et
tant que vous aurez cette envie vous
êtes en vie mais si donc l'arbitré morts
aviez vous avez un honneur non et alors
à ce moment là effectivement vous vous
savez tous voulu rappeler la vérité
voulu rappeler les débuts de santé
mensongers donc il a du mal avec vous à
part ce moment-là il sait que la
médecine traditionnelle
ne peut plus rien pour lui il est comme
vous venez de le dire en face
de l'autre face du miroir et je
représente non seulement celui qui
traîne la balise de la mort depuis 14
ans mais en plus
mon impuissance dans la qualité de la
médecine que j'apporte à réaliser un
musicien un miracle comme on me l'a dit
faites un deuxième miracle et non je ne
peux pas faire à partir de ce moment-là
il connaît mme may psychorigidité comme
il l'appelle luthérien comme il le dit
et il
va se tourner vers d'autres médecines un
peu parallèle un petit peu hors d'usagé
et il ne m'entraîne pas dans ce jeu et
je ne me laisse pas entraîner dans ce
jeu par rapport à ces médecines c'est
vous qui l'aurait amené le genre et le
docteur tarot est un excellente
anesthésistes et qui est
spécialiste de la douleur
or à partir de 1993 il commence à avoir
mal donc je fais appel à jean pierre
thareau je vais le chercher et un bon
bain
il faut il faut faire quelque chose et
donc gens bien tard or entre un petit
peu là et effectivement je pense que
pour n'importe quel malade
le l'homme qui vous suppriment la
douleur quelles que soient les drogues
qu'on donne pour supprimer cette douleur
devient quelque chose de très important
assure il donné quoi de la morphine
je n'étais pas dans ses bagages mais
c'était si moi j'avais été achats en
charge c'est ce que j'aurais donné mais
c'est très vraisemblable est-ce qu'on
peut gouverner un pays en étant souvent
et bien écouté pendant une courte
période je dis bien une courte période
il n'était pas apte et qu'ils étaient
très gênés par un set bien c'est bien
parce que quand vous donnez un certain
nombre de chose à quelqu'un quel qu'il
soit que j'appelle chauffeur de taxi un
président de la république ou le pape il
y a des conséquences je pense que si
quelqu'un était
le pilote de la 747 et qui était avec
des thérapies serait de par la médecine
du travail arrêtée alors vous apprendrez
la mort de françois mitterrand par les
journaux personnes de la famille ne vous
a prévenu pourquoi la famille non mais
jean piat tao m'a appelé en me disant
7 heures du matin juin huit jours après
le décès de l'ancien président vous
publié chez plon un livre intitulé le
grand secret où vous révéler
effectivement que le cancer avait été
diagnostiqué dès 1981 que les bulletins
de santé mensongers et que dès 1994 le
président mitterrand n'était plus
vraiment capable d'assumer ses fonctions
en deux jours vous vendez 40000 livre
donc un livre que vous avez créé être
michel gonnot pourquoi avez vous écrit
ce livre parce que je le lui avais dit
que j'écrivais que ne maintenant que
c'était sur la place publique qu'il
avait un cancer je remettais des choses
en place chaque fois que je le voyais
musée alors avec un sourire ironique où
en sont vos notes et je rappellerai pour
ceux qui ne savent pas que dans un livre
écrit par
monsieur benhamou qui serait le dernier
mitterrand il dit que
le dernier réveillon ou avec jason wu
des ortolans il parle vous savez guibert
écrit un livre donc avant qu'il meure on
savait que j'écrivais un livre vous
aviez choisi michel gonnot parce qu'à
l'époque vous lui avait filé des
mauvaises informations elle n'est pas
bien sûr avec mon sourire ironique donc
là et donc la bouffe est le livre à la
vue de cette série c'est l'un des choix
là alors là évidemment vous devenez
extrêmement médiatiquement célèbre
quelles ont été les réactions au moment
de la publication du livre est lent il y
a eu un tollé général et que je peux
comprendre compte tenu de la dda courte
période dans la mort et la publication
du livre
que je n'ai pas pu arrêter mais bon qui
n'aurait pas eu lieu si le livre était
paru trois mois ou six mois après bien
sûr c'est la date qui qui qui est
surtout
polémiste lien cc c'est pas c'est pas le
livre lui-même donc une levée de
boucliers politique un médecin un bon ça
a été une période
de chocs de difficulté que ce soit cette
médiatisation que je m'attendais pas du
tout deux journalistes qui me court
après de nous de vous avoir d'avocat
d'avocats
plus ou moins retors et méchant je ne
citerai pas dedans mon b tout le monde
comprendra un truc qui je veux parler
personne personne
n'a dit mais attendez avant de mourir
françois mitterrand voulait trois choses
la vérité sur sa fille mazarine la
vérité sur avec payant sur la sphère
bousquet oui et la vérité sur sa santé
quelqu'un aurait dit ça
tout partait les proches les amis mais
je savais et le savez vous voulez trois
choses
la vérité c'est la raison pour laquelle
il m'avait dit vous dirai la vérité vous
êtes un psychorigide herrlisheim et vous
dirai la vérité alors est ce que ce
livre a rapporté de l'argent pas du tout
dans un premier temps il a été interdit
après après l'aval arrêt de la cour
européenne y est reparu mais
l'essai de cette cet ouvrage les comme
on dit les
les droits d'auteur ont été
intégralement versé à ma commune nous
sommes en rien la première portait
pendant toute cette époque donc avec
mitterrand oui quel a été le meilleur
moment
je ne dis pas le les meilleurs moments
qui sûr qu'ils sont tous les mêmes c'est
des moments de solitude à 2 en se
promenant pourparlers 1 et le pire
moment de toute cette époque un moment
où du rêve 82e choses comme ça où il a
voulu arrêter son traitement
est là où je lui ai dit attendez c'est
fini si vous arrêtez j'ai besoin d'être
là je
mentais les plus lents et soignée et
ainsi vous en dire le traitement alors
deux jours après la publication du grand
secret le livre est retiré de la vente à
la demande de la famille mitterrand vous
êtes condamné à quatre mois de prison
avec sursis pour violation du secret
médical et 50000 euros de dommages et
intérêts et radié de l'ordre des
médecins c'est beaucoup la langue ça
s'appelle le un coup de massue sur la
tête traduisent leur peau pour écraser
le mot juin radié de l'ordre des
médecins c'était le professeur glorion
qui à l'époque était résidente du
conseil national de l'ordre des médecins
or comme vous le savez je n'exerçais pas
moins chuté inspecteur général des
affaires sociales n'était pas médecin je
ne vivais pas de mes revenus et de
médecins tant que ça n'était on va leur
dire qu'ils sont fous et que j'ai moi de
l'expression ça te fait quoi on leur a
dit il doit toujours vivre avec il est
fonctionnaire et pointures vie ce qui
n'empêchait pas le conseil national de
l'ordre de me recevoir avec un tapis
rouge enfin parce que j'étais inspecteur
général spécial et que j'ai réglé les
problèmes de l'application des mesures
européennes sur les professionnels de
santé voyez il ya une espèce de cette
affaire est une espèce de drôlerie de la
vie option ce n'est qu'en 2005 que la
cour européenne de justice vous demain à
raison le livre est réédité et donc
depuis on peut le trouver pop seul en
vente libre du banc alors là aujourd'hui
vous êtes nostalgique de cette époque de
l'hélice brin du touât bon ça vous
manque pas du tout aux arcanes du
pouvoir du non pas du tout j'ai jamais
été d'ailleurs dans les arcanes du
pouvoir un du tout pas du tout fait de
la rancune contre quelqu'un l'a reconnu
d'un mot que j'aime pas mais il ya des
êtres humains je n'aime pas beaucoup
hein alors j'en citerai un
monsieur georges kiejman ouais georges
kiejman parce que si l'on se rappelle
bien les faits à un moment donné
danielle mitterrand a dit mais non mais
non je ne veux pas que dublin de la
prison carlos comme ça et madame ezratty
qui était président de la cour d'appel
dit mais attendez donc on arrête tout et
j manette allait revoir dernier non
alors que daniel aurait été dur bon vous
aviez soigner son mari pendant tellement
d'années oui c'est pour ça que avec le
recul même le juge de la chambre qui m'a
condamné dit en privé que c'est une des
des
jugements qui lui reste en travers de la
gorge parce que en dix ans mais n'a
jamais dit qu'il le met ses mains c'est
une des affaires qui la lui maintenant
d'autres le plus d'aidés plus si je puis
dire docteur si c'était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil
je crois que dans la vie
les échecs qu'ils soient professionnels
ou sentimentaux les coups de bâton
c'est positif
pour moi donc
les choses ne seraient peut-être pas des
mêmes parce que les évènements noterez
pts à eux mêmes mais je ne changerait
pas d'un iota votre attitude mon
attitude elle même elle changerait pas
c'est comme ça j'ai fait ce que j'avais
à faire je continue à faire ce que je
fais c'est que je suis comme je suis
alors le jour et les mauvais en caisse
ou les comme écrivent sur votre tombe
sur ma tombe sera écrit fougue lyon
aurait les heures s'enfuit accès doun
ténébres et les ténèbres arrive look so
terminé ternes ou manette mais la
lumière demeure dans l'éternité alors
est ce que comme françois mitterrand
vous croyez aux forces de l'esprit
ne s'est pas de mots j'en ferais moi je
suis plus croyants si je puis dire mais
ça peut se rejoindre
je pense que il ya quelque chose qui
subliment notre cher propres le fait
même de se parler commence par un fait
qu'il ya quelque chose qui reste et
c'est ce quelque chose qui pour moi est
la lumière dans l'éternité très bien
merci j'étais très heureux de rallumer
la lumière sur le meurtre
[Musique]
j'accueille philippe la vie
il vit sa vie au porno coco est au piano
l'amour en photo sont plus porte à tout
âge
il vit sa vie comme un foudre
vincent
bienvenue
tempo
il tape sur des bambous et ses numéros
dans son nid dans les fous comme des
musiciens
sur un nuage à valley il a eu au corps
dix femmes sa musique ça lui va bien
[Musique]
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
philippe lavil dans le xviie
arrondissement de paris comme tous les
matins ils descendent prendre son petit
déjeuner au café en bas de chez lui
ça va être petit croissant ou
décroissant avec petit mais miel
abondant parce que
la dernière fois tu m'as mis 3 goutte de
miel je trouvais ça
j'ai trouvé ça un peu ras j'aime bien la
rue qui s'éveille les gens pour connaît
les commerçants du coin des tice silos
et la petite merde il ya tous ces
chiffres
je lis le parisien tous les jours ont
besoin d'un stylo je fais les niveaux
fléchi quand ils sont pas faits je fais
le sudoku
et là
mon petit cerveau c'est bien en place et
je peux commencer à pouvoir me laver les
dents avec une vraie brosse à dents
plutôt qu'avec un rasoir ça me réveille
oui mais oui mais je rentre parce qu'il
fait rentrer parce que ça caille on peut
tu vois
je te remercie ça me dit ah d'amour je
bossais mois
à plus tard
des packs pendant la salle de boxe
bien habillé le chanteur prend ensuite
la route pour une journée de come back à
leur voiture hu est un peu à la bourre
alors là nous allons répéter
une émission de télévision dans les
studios de patrick sébastien je vais
chanter un pot-pourri de chansons
de très très connus y aura qu une tape
sur des bambous bon ça c'est normal
parce que c'est quand même
c'est quand même entre guillemets mon
code barre arrivé au studio
d'enregistrement il fait sa tournée de
bonjour
ça va bien ça va très bien
merci
ça va domota qui nagent pas dit bonjour
comment allez vous sans oublier l'hôte
de maison patrick sébastien
et c'est parti pour la répétition est un
chanteur professionnel philippe lavil
est toujours exigeant
quand je connais tout épicé
[Musique]
le patriote monsieur
fin de la répétition ils filent chez son
cordonnier préféré égoïste monsieur la
ville est un amoureux de la belle
chaussures bon j'aurais fait jour
oliva notamment les tartes de des deux
côtés la somparé sont pas les mêmes moi
je préfère ça à ça voilà ce que j'aime
c'est c'est la matière si vous voulez je
peux pas je peux pas me balader avec un
os à com comment s'appellera attachés
qu'ils en plastique quoi on se caille
en plastique je te vois nous on fait un
peu un métier d'artisan quand on fait
nos petites chansonnettes c'est un peu
c'est de l'artisanat pour moi c'est
comme ça que je refasse c'est comme ça
que je considère et eux aussi ce sont
des sons un peu d artistes sont des
artisans des artistes salut merci
au revoir les filles oui je fonce parce
que là je vais vraiment à la bourse
salue souriant et bien chaussé philippe
lavil repart toujours pressé
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
philippe lavil bienvenue sur le plateau
de tout le monde en a parlé alors
philippe vous êtes né le 26 septembre
1947 à fort de france en martinique sous
le nom de philippe durand de ville jégu
dû freiner aux parents sont des antilles
et blanc des békés dont la famille s'est
installée dans les îles depuis 1750 et
un truc comme ça mais on a retrouvé des
ancêtres à cette époque là j'avais d'où
il venait en france alors dans la région
nantaise
et de bretagne votre père exploite des
débats mènerait au village du françois
vous habitez et votre mère est
l'héritière du rhum bally ouais t'as mis
riches alors pas du tout non pas du tout
ce que j'avais un grand père qui était
espèces d'humaniste un bonhomme qui avec
a créé le vieillissement du rhum en fût
de chêne c'est lui qui a mis ça au point
au début du siècle dernier il a fait
lecture et des copains il a eu dix
enfants on l'a revu ses livres de compte
c'était dont un machin pour bercy il a
fait des petites soeurs des pauvres les
petits frères des pauvres donc c'est un
type l'argent n'avait absolument aucune
importance pour lui alors enfance très
jolie dans une petite maison coloniale
cerné par une luxuriante végétation
tropicale à 6 km de la route la plus
proche on a vécu dans cet endroit là un
peu comme des des robinsons quoi alors
là vous pêchez les écrevisses vous
monter à cheval enfin une vie de rêve
ouais on apprend à chasser avec des
lance pierres j'ai un souvenir
incroyable de cette époque là quand
votre mère qui chantait bien avait rêvé
d'une carrière artistique et sur les
conseils de louis jouvet qu'elle avait
rencontré lors d'une tournée de jouer
aux antilles pendant la guerre elle
était venue en métropole en 1945 mais
elle s'était trompée de métro elle
n'avait jamais eu le rendez-vous qui
aurait pu la conduire vers l'art lyrique
elle s'est trompée de métro et je pense
qu'elle était déjà un peu amoureuse de
mon père et puis
quand je suis né ça a été un enfantement
difficile et sa voix était très abîmé et
vous en faites vous êtes un peu devenu
chanteur par atavisme vous vivez un peu
sa vie par procuration une certaine
façon mais je m'en suis rendu compte un
jour en fait j c'est bizarre quand tu es
perdu ta voix et que j'en ai fait mon
métier alors pendant mon enfance vous
écoutez de la salsa sur radio cuba et
des musiques antillaises sur les radio
en ondes moyennes qui avait là-bas à
l'époque c'était la biguine c'était les
vieilles les vieilles mélodies relais
magnifiques mélodies créole qui font
partie du patrimoine
les grands orchestres du père d'eddy
louiss par exemple et la radio diffusait
aussi du jazz beaucoup de jazz et de la
musique l'est mais en 1960 quand vous
débarquez en métropole vous découvrez le
rock'n'roll j'entends des premiers
hallyday j'entends les premiers
chaussettes noires vie qu'est ce que
c'est et puis les beatles tout de suite
les beatles les stones crime voilà dès
que j'entendais un truc qui me branche
est un peu je l'achetais donc c'est
comme ça qu'un jour j'ai un album de
crime et et puis cet album c'est devenir
l'album de chevet pour un album culte
que j'ai toujours d'ailleurs faits par
la suisse et dans un pensionnat dans la
drôme à dieulefit que vous êtes initié à
la musique par votre prof d'anglais
qu'il est autre que grimm online quand
même regretter à l'époque prof il nous
expliquer comment
pourquoi le pourquoi des choses ça c'est
une jolie phrase musicale pour ça pour
ça et ça c'était vachement intéressante
comme voir un match de rugby avec à côté
de jean pierre rives quoi
là vous acheter une guitare vous rêvez
de devenir chanteur mais vos parents
vous colle trois ans dans une école de
commerce ou vous monter des groupes
quand même j'avais monté de on avait
monté deux groupes on faisait les alors
c'était bondé les kermesses on faisait
des soirées mondaines
mes hommages madame tous en smokings
c'était assez rigolo et puis on jouait
pour pour nous pour rigoler quoi alors
vous sortez un premier 45 tours en 1969
qui s'appelle à laquelle ils font chaoui
les militaires quand ils allaient en
permission à fort de france il était
demandé dans des camionnettes de l'armée
puis taper comme ça sur la camionnette
pachins et faisait à la kali à la kali
halak a dû fauchon mezam i say what may
abysses et wap ça veut dire je vais la
sauter je vais je vais me trouver une
bonzesse et je vais la démonter
quand je suis arrivé à auxerre en france
des gens ont trouvé ça rigolo mais en
même temps mes potes antillais disette
et quand même gonflé de quand même fier
de dire ça mais je dis c'est pas grave
bon après ça il ya déjà eu ce fameux
groupe saïan supa crew qui avait fait
angela en quechua pendant pas par palace
qui veut dire angela je vais te défoncer
pendant que ton père n'est pas la voie
là et tout ça s'est passé à la radio
alors le deuxième c'est sur une musique
de billy bridges avec les filles je ne
sais pas ça ça marche bien deuxième
succès ben je comprends pas d'ailleurs
ce qui m'arrive ouais en fait parce que
c'était pas le genre de chansons avec
lesquelles j'avais envie de me faire
connaître quoi pour moi ça a été un coup
comme ça voilà le problème si vous
pensez plus à vous amuser cabossée c'est
l'époque où vous fréquentez caroline de
monaco qui à 17 ans à l'époque je me
suis jamais exprimé à propos de caroline
de hanovre maintenant monaco pour deux
raisons la première raison c'est que
j'ai fait le serment à son père le
prince rainier la seule fois que j'ai vu
que jamais de ma vie je n'en parlerai
donc je m'y tiendrai d'accord je
continuerai à m'y tenir on m'a proposé
de l'argent pour éclairer un livre j'ai
dis donc beaucoup d'argent je dis bon la
deuxième c'est que nous avons tous les
deux fait nos vies que nous avons des
enfants et que je pense que le passé des
parents pour des enfants
je sais pas moi demain d'ouvrir ma
gueule donc un amour de jeunesse louis à
battre est jolie mais une histoire oui
l'histoire merveilleuse délicieux
charmante voilà je ne garde que ce
souvenir formidable quoi l'album suivant
ne marche pas vous partez de chez vera
vous êtes obligé d'autoproduire vaut 45
tours c'est la galère est là devant
l'échec de votre carrière vous envisagez
de changer d'activité de retourner à la
martinique vous achetez un aller simple
mais toujours je crois et avant de
partir vous misez sur un titre écrit
avec didier barbelivien il tape sur des
bambous ouais voilà c'est c'est le tube
de l'été un million et demi
d'exemplaires vendus un truc comme ça et
et bob ce qu'est un jour m'appelle et me
dit le garde garde ta voix tu regardes
ton n'a pas garde ta chaîne stéréo ne
retourne pas en partie déchire
tourbillon fait doivent rembourser
tombiez voilà ce qui se passe il sait
pas c'est énorme un truc énorme bref
sinon vous auriez fait quoi en
martinique souhaitent y retourner j'sais
pas moi j'avais envie d'aller faire du
tourisme
bosser faire un petit hôtel depuis sa
chambre spèce de vie
d'ailleurs peut-être que je la ferai ça
demain j'en sais rien alors trois ans
plus tard nouveau tube elle barbelivien
elle préfère l'amour en mer énorme
musiques de films je faisais un album à
l'époque qui s'appelait nonchalance
pendant qu'on enregistre l'album
michelle lang me demande une musique
pour un film qui s'appelait à nous les
garçons j'avais des chances on avance et
je lui fais écouter ça c'est un truc
qu'on avait depuis des années qu'on
n'arrivait pas à paroles est quand même
fou j'appelle barbelivien jours à 7h du
soir jeudi didier demain matin 10h j'ai
besoin d'un texte sur l ael à la la ça
s'appelait comme ça et là et là là là le
lendemain il m'apporte le truc je chante
je fais deux prises de voix je retourne
je retourne jouer au flipper avec eddy
mitchell qui étaient d'anciens de
récolter
les costa vient de faire les voix 4
heures de l'après midi c'était bouclé
j'ai repris la vente de poteries d'amont
l'enregistrement de mon album
quand le la musique du film est sorti il
ya une attachée de presse de jeu me
saison qui a dit c'est un tube qui est
allé voir les radios c'est devenu un
tube ouais et puis en même temps cette
chanson je lui en ai voulu à mort parce
qu'elle m'a flingué bon album qui venait
derrière
c'est un peu toute votre histoire ça
c'est à dire en fait vous fait des gros
tubes formidable que tout le monde a
encore en mémoire et parallèlement s'est
obscurci un peu votre carrière de
réelles chanteur auteur compositeur sur
des choses un peu plus sophistiqué que
je pense ouais ouais ça commence à me
gênait énormément
même inventé le freeze le frisbee un
jean et des il y avait toujours de très
jolie pochette / br / les singles qu'on
faisait jef d'une à ce qu'ils étaient un
photographe américain de charme qui
m'avait fait la photo des bambous jean
baptiste mondino et c'est donc belle
pochette dont québec garda les pochettes
et il m'a envoyé le disque ce projet là
je prends les règles donc jamais au bout
d'un moment c'est un peu gonflant
deux ans plus tard collé-serré jocelyne
beroard encore pareil la chanteuse de
kassav énorme tube j'appelle ça détruit
moment magique seat la chanson
l'écoutent
on peut l'écouter 20 fois dire c'est
vachement bien on la chante une fois il
ya les
espèces de chair de poule qui se mâche
ans et on s'est dit si je la chante pas
je suis un gros con donc j'allais voir
jocelyne j'écoute il faut qu'on fasse ça
on l'a fait alors grosse célébrité à ce
moment là quelles ont été les réactions
de votre entourage présent votre mère a
dit quoi à ce moment là j'ai la chance
d'avoir pu et d'avoir toujours une
famille
qui pour qui la célébrité l'argent le le
succès tout ça
quand je suis à la maison on ne manque
de changer des ampoules de portes
descendre les poubelles de mes petits
neveux me saute sur les genoux et voit
pas la chanteuse quoi il voit juste un
oncle ou à leur entente avec l'aîné gaz
s'est toujours bien passé n'ont jamais
de problèmes n'ont jamais si on m'a fait
au moment de mon divorce je crois qu'on
va effet une page dans voici oui mais
bon ça m'a rien de non non rien de
salace rien les gars vous allez gagner
de l'argent j'ai gagné pas mal d'argent
mais vous avez mis de côté non j'avais
mis de côté j'avais mis oui évidemment
j'avais mis de côté donc j'avais une
famille donc on avait acheté deux bien
enfin en tout cas un bien et moi un
petit peu d'âme d'un autre bien mais
comme beaucoup de couples g monsieur
séparé de ma femme et puis à un moment
il faut il faut faut privilégier gelé
les enfants souvent les enfants sont
petits ouais le pognon mais après tout
j'ai jamais couru après ça non plus quoi
c'est pas l'argent mon père n'était pas
un homme d'argent les grands parents
n'étaient pas des gens d'argent
le savent quand j'en avais j'en avais
quand j'en avais pas quand je n'ai pas
j'en ai pas je m'en fous - est alors
question amour c'est évidemment cette
formidable non parce que vous êtes
séduisant c'est vrai j'ai vécu de très
jolis moments c'est vrai
de 83,95 j'ai été mariée et une fidélité
réciproque
immuable c'est à dire que comme j'ai
l'habitude de dire un peu vulgairement
même pour 50 balles au bois de boulogne
jamais quoi quel était le meilleur
moment de cette époque philippe il ya un
moment 88 qui a été pour moi extrêmement
important c'est le jour où on avait fait
de la pia tout seul quoi je vais tout
seul pendant une semaine on avait loué
et mon père est venu le jour de la
première
il était au deuxième rang et
ima il est venu me voir dans la loge
après il m'a embrassée et bat regarder
et ce jour là j'ai compris dans son
regard qui me disait
tu as quand même bien fait de te battre
pour arriver à faire ça parce que pile
et morale ans après voilà donc il a eu
le temps de me dire que j'avais eu
raison bon moment et le pire moment de
toute cette époque je crois que c'est en
97 lorsque je me suis retrouvée exemple
je faisais 58 kg avec une luminaires d
aucun accident là
le les deux plateaux de la balance
le moral qui est technique était par
terre le physique qui était par terre et
une adversité
qu'ils étaient difficilement supportable
quoi là ça a été quelque chose de je
pense était quelque chose de terrible et
quelque part je me demande si c'est pas
plus mal parce que c'était déjà l'est
tellement mal
que je me suis dit si je sors pas de là
je vais pas pouvoir me regarder dans la
glace vous êtes nostalgique aujourd'hui
de cette époque non non vous ne votez
pas à l'époque des bambous l'époque de
connaissez être est ce parce que j'en ai
d'autres sous le coude bon j'en ai fait
d'autres et puis chaque fois que je fais
une chanson je le dis à la nostalgie ne
m'atteint pas quoi le passé c'est le
passé et si c'était à refaire votre vie
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil je prendrai un avocat pour mon
premier contrat
je pense que ça aurait évité cinq ans de
cinq ans de presque d'interdiction
d'aller en studio donc ce qui m'a permis
de faire des chansons en faire beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup mais je pense que je
j'ai fait confiance je ferai peut-être
moins confiance à des gens qui froid
c'était comme ça que ça se passait aussi
à l'époque donc assez le show business
ouais c'était le show biz c'est pour ça
que je déteste ce mot la main le jour
vous allez mourir qu'elle voulait qu'on
écrive sur votre tombe
pas si mal que ça le mec ouais
merci très heureux de revenir sur vos
merci beaucoup thierry
[Musique]
j'accueille hervé claude
hollywood n'est plus ce qu'il était
columbia déjà été rachetées par les
japonais de sony eh bien cette fois
c'est un groupe européen qui attaquent
pathé veut racheter la mgm la fameuse
métro goldwin meyer celle du lion wahaha
comme ça c'est l'association des deux
plus vieux cinéma des deux plus vieux
noms du cinéma mondial
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
hervé claude chez lui en bord de mer
dans le morbihan
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans mon repère breton
venez je vais vous montrer alors on
traverse la maison on est directement
sur la ria en fait parce que c'est une
ria c'est pas vraiment la mer c'est
enfin c'est la mère qui rend l'océan qui
remonte dans la terre ont l'avantagé
d'être au bord de la mer vraiment et ne
pas avoir quand même les violences des
tempêtes de l'océan c'est quand même
beaucoup plus calme et beaucoup plus
doux notamment quand le vent souffle
mais en revanche c'est quand même la mer
juste au bout du jardin et tous les
matins direction la plage à seulement
quelques kilomètres de là le temps pour
hervé des veillées son corps et son
esprit
aura beaucoup sur les plages marchait se
baigner l'était bien sûr sans compter
les dirait qu'on fait plus loin et des
tas de choses à voir dans la région
le matin quand je manque un peu
d'inspiration et bien je viens ici je
marche le long de la plage marche le
long des dunes et ça revient et je
recommence je reviens à la maison pour
travailler ce que ça m'apporte pour
l'écriture au fond c'est plus un
apaisement c'est à dire qu'en fait comme
je suis assis à ma table de travail le
matin je suis un peu énervé je trouve
pas mes idées j'ai pas envie vraiment
décrire etc alors je prends ma voiture
je finis si je marche sur la plage et là
tout d'un coup ça m'apaise je me sens
bien les idées reviennent quand je
rentre à la maison je suis plutôt calme
et et j'ai des idées
[Musique]
et c'est donc apaiser inspiré que
l'ancien journaliste présentateur du
journal télévisé de france 2 peut
retourner à son travail d'écrivain est à
son 17e rond là on arrive dans mon
bureau
ici avec une vue sur la riaa et c'est
ici que je travaille voilà
c'est ici que j'écris en général voilà
j'écris j'écris à la main ça voilà ce
que j'ai fait un peu cet été
une fois que j'ai écrit à la main que le
travail est à peu près fini correctement
je le dis que tu as mon ordinateur avec
un logiciel de reconnaissance vocale et
c'est très agréable parce que ça fait
une lecture à haute voix bon je suis
très inspiré par les lieux dans ma
mémoire etc j'aime beaucoup voyagé donc
souvent mes livres se sont sont partis
ailleurs on son parti voyager mais j'ai
fait deux romans qui se passait en
bretagne qui se passait ici dans cette
maison d'ailleurs que la première fois
je suis parti en australie j'ai une idée
de roman noir j'avais écrit d'autres
romans mais cette fois j'ai eu envie
d'écrire un roman noir je les fais j'ai
donné la série noire ils l'ont pris en
huit jours alors je me suis dit un
l'australie m'inspire ça va servir de
cadre à mes romans en plus appelés aux
éditeurs et aux lecteurs apparemment et
deux comme ça il faut que je retourne en
australie régulièrement ce que j'ai fait
l'australie est désormais son deuxième
port d'attache où il passe tous ses
hivers
à
[Applaudissements]
c'est roman s'inspire de ce pays et de
sa culture qu'il connaît parfaitement
[Applaudissements]
maintenant on va aller faire un petit
tour à vélo c'est chaque jour ce
obligatoire à l'heure du déjeuner comme
ça y'a personne sur les routes c'est
très bien je prends mon petit vélo et
j'y vais
[Musique]
moi ça me détend l'esprit c'est à dire
que effectivement c'est plutôt c'est
plutôt le besoin physique après
l'écriture on est resté à sa table à se
creuser la tête et est à s'ennuyer
parfois aussi un petit peu après une
bonne détente une bonne suée sur le vélo
ça ça fait le plus grand bien
de retour chez lui il retrouve son
compagnon mateille sculpteur devient
partout la maison
quand il partage la vie depuis plus de
vingt ans et qui a son atelier dans la
maison est en train de travailler ou pas
les noirs
n'ont chacun notre espace eu lieu notre
espace
bien sûr qu'à la fin on se retrouve et
on discute pas mal ouais de ce conte de
notre travail
mais on a chacun notre espace donc par
exemple le matin s'ils voient pas
détourner cette fois exactement le sois
moi le matin le soir
mais c'est pas celle que tu avais exposé
chez clara
ça colle avec bonne grâce à fait
complètement différent allez
désormais loin des plateaux de télé
parisien hervé claude peut aujourd'hui
vivre sa vie en toute sérénité
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
hervé claude hervé bienvenue sur plateau
tout le monde en parlait vous êtes né le
19 novembre 1945 à paris exact père
lorrain oui directeur commercial chez
unilever mère bretonne oui père lorrain
mère bretonne comme victor hugo alors
femme au foyer avec cinq enfants ça se
comprend oui et vos parents s'étaient
rencontrés pendant la guerre à paris en
fait exactement vos émoluments oui alors
famille catholique sans histoire
d'ailleurs en france un petit peu
ennuyeuse oui ennuyeux c'est vrai mais
quand je réfléchis c'est quand même une
enfant ce pas protégé mais c'est une
enfant ce formidable parce que j'ai eues
on m'a donné toutes les cartes en main
jeu ça c'est formidable vous dites quand
même j'étais impatient de passer à autre
chose c'est vrai je m'ennuyais l'invite
terriblement au lycée je te pas mauvais
mais je m'emmerdais quoi heureusement il
ya les grandes vacances en bretagne
là tous les ans vos parents louent une
maison art et 9 près de saint malo et là
il ya la voile ah oui ça ça beaucoup
compté c'est à dire que pareille nos
parents étaient très sympas saisit pas
très fortunés mais ils ont acheté un
bateau dès qu'ils ont pu et on a
commencé à naviguer et moi évidemment ça
m'a le virus m'a pris et je fais
beaucoup beaucoup de compétition pendant
12 13 ans on finira en équipe de france
quand même oui oui j'étais jusqu en
équipe de france on a préparé les jeux
olympiques
alors scolarité dans les lycées
montaigne louis-le-grand aucun souvenir
vraiment marquant sauve ce prof de
français qui vous donne le goût de la
lecture en vous obligeant à lire les
classiques ouais mon seul regret c'est
que je me souviens pas de son nom mais à
part ça oui c'était en seconde et c'est
vrai qu'il nous a fait lire toutes les
semaines il fallait qu'on vise un
classique saleh de gobineau à marca
mauroy et c'est donc vraiment ça ça m'a
donné le goût de la lecture de voir si
vous avez des plus tard ah bah oui
ensuite sciences éco et sciences po pas
mal mais pas d'école de journalisme
parce que vous avez pas de vocation
particulière à l'époque dans mon milieu
le milieu de mes parents on connaissait
pas du tout les journalistes dont vous
savez même pas comment comment il
fallait faire pour être journaliste donc
ça ne m'était pas venu à l'esprit mais
sinon j'étais un dévoreur de journaux
depuis tout petit alors vous voulez
écrire et finalement la façon la plus
simple d'écrire cette journée yves-m le
problème c'est que vous ne connaissez
personne voilà c'est ça c'est ça et en
fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que je
faisais des jeux travailler l'été comme
beaucoup d'étudiants etc et j'ai
travaillé à l'insee et j'ai rencontré
l'attaché de presse de l'iec est un
ancien journaliste et qui m'a envoyé
voir des copains à lui pour voir si ça
pouvait m'intéresser marchés etc et il
m'a envoyé un jour voir le fameux
gabriel aranda mais c'est celui de la
feuille d'impôt de chaban-delmas voilà
exactement mais qui était à l'époque à
la fois chef du service économique à la
deuxième chaîne à l'époque s'appelait
même pas antenne 2 et en os qui qui
était chef du service technique d'un
journal c'est l'actualité où j'ai
commencé à travailler c'est quoi
l'actualité c'était un magazine qui
était dirigée par paul marie de la gorce
et un hebdo qui a pas tellement marché
c'est un hebdo un peu gaulliste de
gauche ouais c'était voilà très éphémère
très éphémère mais avec j'ai rencontré
plein de gens y compris françoise kramer
qui est devenue ma femme voilà alors
ensuite france inter est rentré comme
ans à france inter alors c'est pareil
c'est à dire qu'entre temps j'ai fait
mon service militaire je les fait boiter
rien de joie ville puisque je faisais de
la voile à leur compétition et puis
après quand je suis revenu et ben j'ai
été je suis retourné voir tous les
journalistes que j'avais connu dans la
première période j'ai eu une proposition
inter j'ai une proposition à la télé
j'ai choisi plutôt la radio ça me
plaisait plus a priori la télé c'était
ça c'était enfin c'est pas le tout début
mais on se rendait pas compte vraiment
est ce que ça donnait le 1er janvier
1975 vous entrée antenne 2 ouais comment
alors ça c'est l'explosion de loups rtf
à l'époque jusqu'à a fait exploser le
rtf dans les différentes sociétés et il
se trouve que les chaînes de télé avait
envie de renouveler les visages mais il
n'avait pas le droit de piocher hors du
vivier deleware tf est donc en tout ce
qui était à france inter à l'époque
gildas poivre d'arvor a marre benyamine
tous on est tous passés à la télé à ce
moment là ou presque sont passés à la
une et moi je suis assez d'accord alors
là c'est quand même la célébrité vous
faites le journal pendant pratiquement
une quinzaine d'années quelles ont été
les réactions de votre entourage quand
on vous a vu présenter le journal
télévisé beaux parents oui mes parents
enfin je sais pas si ça les bleus fait
vraiment je crois qu'ils étaient
contents pour moi c'était bien il
c'était sympa mais ce n'était pas
extraordinaire quoi je pense que pour
faire un petit saut dans l'avenir après
ils ont été beaucoup plus bluffé le jour
où je suis passé apostrophe avec brio
par exemple mais voilà ça ça les a fait
qu'ils étaient vraiment fier mais
autrement journal bon j'étais
journaliste soit bon
avec les médias avait jamais eu de
problème j'ai toujours été très bien
traité par les professions presque très
bien pour temps en temps j'ai eu
quelques quelques méchants méchants très
réaction par exemple je me souviens d'un
jour c'était drôle parce que j'ai
interviewés marché au 20 heures puis
c'était aussi c'était l'époque où il
était passé ses vacances chez rocher ce
coup alors évidemment j'avais eu
quelques questions un peu pointu non
dans l'interview et notamment je vais
couper la parole ont des passés à autre
chose et j'avais eu le droit à la une de
rouge avec les grossiers de l'écran
comme sympathique bon titre en
question argent vous avez pas gagné
beaucoup d'argent à l'époque au pas mal
quand même enfin je veux dire je n'ai
pas gagné beaucoup d'argent on sait pas
c'est pas j'ai eu un salaire qui a
progressé mais c'est vrai que le jour on
fait le 20 heures on devient le salaire
le plus important de la rédaction quoi
c'est clair donc ce qui fait d'ailleurs
souvent une petite césure une tétine
césure avec les autres parfois etc voilà
mais autrement oui c'était le service
public comme un donc c'était pas non
plus aujourd'hui un ami d'argent de côté
pour plus tard disons pas trop de
patronne alors question un mot en 1976
vous divorcez de la journaliste
françoise kramer en fait vous êtes gay
mais vrai jamais de coming out c'est à
dire vous dites dans cette démarche il
ya la volonté d' avouer je trouve ça
terrible c'est comme la sphère levinsky
cet oiseau fille de l'aveu à l'anglo
saxonne c'est pas votre truc dont je
déteste ça écrit en plus je pense qu'il
ya un autre élément c'est à dire enfin
je sais pas comment ça se passe chez les
américains ils sont plus souvent dans le
placard moi j'ai jamais été dans le
placard à dire quand il dans les
rédactions vous travail et on le savait
on va voilà j'ai vécu avec françoise
après bon je suis passé à autre chose
j'ai aimé dans les rédactions ou mes
amis tout le monde savaient qu'ils
vivaient les shebab j'ai jamais caché
quoi que ce soit moi jamais non plus
poser directement la question donc et et
après quand on a lu vos bouquins c'est
devenu très clair abbas est devenu plus
clair alors à ce moment là on n'en parle
plus évidemment enfin en 2009 comme dans
libération vous avez annoncé que vous
étiez pacsé avec mattei negreanu qui est
un sculpteur sur verre donc voilà je fus
ramzy on est souvent ensemble ça fait 22
ans qu'on est ensemble maintenant
croiser alors qu'elle a été le meilleur
moment de cette époque du journal
télévisé sur sur antenne 2 ce qui est
formidable toujours c'est les rencontres
même très brève qu'on peut avoir trois
minutes d'interview avec des personnes à
c'est exceptionnel de barbara hendricks
à des hommes politiques présents de la
république le point vis et ça c'est
vraiment des moments forts si vous
voulez mais finalement je trouve ses
austères le journal donc les vrais
moments de télé où je me suis amusé
c'est parfois quand on allait chanter
chez drucker en bande avec
avec zabel et holtz ou des trucs comme
ça qu'on a fait souvent d'ailleurs je
passais dans notre à des missions donc
ça va paraître des moments de bonheur
par rapport à la difficulté les
travaille même enthousiasme ans qu'on
faisait au journal mais comme un moment
marrant c'est un jour en fin de journal
hier le réalisateur ne coupe pas le
plateau vous savez plus quoi faire et
vous cacher sous bureau entre marans
mais c'était amusant parce qu'en fait
j'avais vu ça dans un film américain
c'était un film à sketchs est bon tout
cela je n'ai pas voulu leur faire c'est
exactement mais c'est vrai que j'ai
senti que le générique ne partait pas et
je me trouvais à l'antenne et qu'il rien
le plus bête que de son stylo et serra
et donc j'ai dit à mon assistante qui
était dans le derrière la caméra je dis
chiche que je dise sous le bureau elle
m'a dit pas cap évidemment
on en parle encore mais on parle encore
c'est ça qui est fou quand j'ai fait le
journal pendant presque vingt ans
environ contre ces cancers
quel a été le pire moment de cette
époque moi j'ai pas beaucoup de
souvenirs mauvais souvenir que je les ai
fasse vite mais à la réflexion je me
suis dit qu'elle avait un qui était
quand même vraiment pas bien ça a été au
monde la guerre du golfe est ce qu'au
moment de la guerre du golfe là je
faisais le 20h on faisait des émissions
spéciales etc et d'abord on avait très
peu d'informations et on s'est aperçu
très vite on les senti très vite d'abord
que c'était très anxiogène par rapport à
ce qu'ont montré etc et ensuite qu'on se
faisait manipuler complètement par
l'information américaine et là on a tous
eu je crois un sentiment vraiment très
désagréable hélas après vingt ans de
maison en 1995 jean pierre elkabbach
vous vire mais pourquoi il faudrait lui
demander à
des amis qui à la place
qui avait à l'époque bruno mais qui
bruno masure mais qui faisait déjà le
journal je sais plus chez nous alors et
si après il ya eu etienne leenhardt
voilà c'est vrai qu'il avait plus de
pression possible sur etienne leenhardt
que sur vous c'est possible moi je
l'avais connu dans une autre vie jean
pierre elkabbach puisqu'il avait été
notre rédacteur en chef entre 77 et 80
et que ça s'était très mal passé pas
seulement pour moi donc il vous vire
ensuite j'allais sur arte forum planète
être sur france 2 vous reviendrai pour
faire à gap et l'excellente émission c
il va vous ne serez plus jamais exposé
médiatiquement comme vous l'avez été au
moment du journal j'ai presque envie de
dire tant mieux nostalgique de sa pa de
l'alpa de la notoriété non je peux être
nostalgique parfois de certaines choses
par exemple c'est vrai quand j'arrive
sur un plateau de télé comme ici
l'ambiance de télé les caméras qui
tourne préparation ce même s'il faut
attendre et toujours ça sympa et encore
sur ce dont je serai un peu plus
nostalgiques c'est le travail collectif
à la rédaction par exemple les
conférences de rédaction de 15 heures
mais c'est quand même un souvenir
formidable et de temps en temps je me
dis ah quand il ya un événement
politique j'aimerais hier voilà et
d'ailleurs quand je suis passé à arte il
ya eu le 11 septembre et ce jour là
comme je faisais les thémas mais je
faisais pas de l'actualité quotidienne
je me suis retrouvé sans rédaction plus
tard l'action était à strasbourg moi
j'étais à paris et j'avais pas de
rédaction où aller pour vivre
l'événement avec les autres journalistes
travailler s'il fallait et c'est là je
me suis sentie francis à qui vous manque
et de la rancune contre jean pierre
elkabbach par exemple n'en parlons pas
oui
inutile alors si c'était à refaire votre
vie qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil hervé et ben je crois non
franchement je crois que presque tous à
part une ou deux ou nude aux petites
mais c'est de l'anecdote le jour vous
allez mourir cassoulet qu'on marque sur
votre tombe j'ai envie de dire choisis
ta vie je crois que c'est
moi j'ai choisi ma vie il me semble dans
tous les domaines que ce soit
professionnel affectif amoureux et c est
bon alors évidemment il ya aussi saisis
ta chance parce que il faut avoir ses
chances là je les ai eues mais à un
moment il faut savoir choisir sa vie et
être se débarrasser des contraintes
sociales familiales et autres merci
avait été très heureux de rallumer la
lumière sur vos merci merci thierry
c'était tout le monde en à barlest amis
du bar king bonsoir
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu